la nouvelle copine de Léon Leonardo
DiCaprio à 19 ans donc voilà
on sait qu'il aime les femmes plus
jeunes que lui c'était 27 à 25 24 23 là
on a 19 on est un an de il y a quelques
mois donc on vous en parlez dès que
c'est une petite copine pas de 25 ans il
se sépare d'elle au moins au moins
pardon elle connaissent exactement les
termes du contrat aujourd'hui dans le
viseur des internautes puisque ça peut
être copine à 19 ans 29 ans de moins que
lui et alors c'est un top model elle est
magnifique regardez
[Musique]
c'est l'un des plus grands acteurs de sa
génération mais également l'un des plus
grands séducteurs de Hollywood je vis
mon rêve à bientôt 50 ans Léonardo
Dicaprio multiplie les conquêtes
féminines et la superstar un petit
penchant bien connu pour les femmes plus
jeunes que lui
la rumeur en date l'acteur serait en
couple avec une mannequin
franco-israélienne de 29 ans acadède
avec qui il a été photographié lors
d'une soirée privée à Los Angeles
cette relation entre DiCaprio et cette
jeune fille de 19 ans a créé la
polémique outre-Atlantique et la star de
Titanic s'est fait lyncher sur les
réseaux sociaux en se faisant traiter de
pervers quelqu'un peut m'expliquer ce
qu'un homme de presque 50 ans en commun
avec une femme proche de la vingtaine
Léonardo Dicaprio se préoccupe du
changement climatique car il veut
laisser un monde meilleur à ses
compagnes la chérie de Leonardo est si
jeune que ces années au collège ont été
interrompues par la pandémie de covid
pour éteindre la polémique des proches
de l'acteurs ont affirmé qu'il ne se
passait absolument rien entre eux pour
l'instant l'acteur se dit toujours
célibataire j'ai besoin d'un peu de
temps pour savoir ce que je vais faire
ensuite mais le passé de la star qui est
souvent sorti avec de très jeunes femmes
de plates pas en sa faveur bref Léonardo
Dicaprio traité de pervers par les
internautes comprenez-vous
[Musique]
êtes-vous choqué par choqué
pendant la le sujet j'ai essayé de
calmer Ludivine mais mais on a
l'impression qu'on a piqué son mecs
alors on va l'écouter je n'en veux pas
du tout c'était vraiment
un de mes acteurs préférés au monde le
loup de Wall Street Titanic j'en passe
et les meilleurs Arrête-moi si tu peux
je l'adore ce mec sauf qu'au fil des ans
son petit stratagèmes de prédateurs qui
veut tout est là toujours aller chercher
des gamines pour avoir une emprise
psychologique sur ses gamines pourquoi
tu vois je comptais
bébé alors que je t'aime je vous
explique la jeune fille à ses côtés je
vais m'oublier son prénom elle a le même
âge que ma fille ma fille va fêter son
19e anniversaire dans 15 jours ça me
répugne ça me dégoûte parce qu'à chaque
fois qu'elles atteignent 25 ans il les
jarte alors je ne sais pas si vous
entendez par là des contrats tout le
monde y trouve son compte c'est juste
dégueulasse c'est un prédateur sexuel un
vieux dégueulasse de 50 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la vérité elle est extrême c'est une
enflée
va consulter un médecin
tu peux avoir des boutons c'est
peut-être pour ça que ça mon dernier
rendez-vous il a pas compris ce que je
lui demandais
déjà les mots doivent garder un son
écoute tu dis prédateur sexuel
franchement tu as de la chance comme dit
Mathieu qui soit américain parce que là
c'est Émile Louis le prédateur sexuel
c'est Francisco mais cetera c'est pas
Léonardo
capriote tu peux dire qu'elle serait un
peu vénale qu'elle veut se faire sa pub
etc ils sont chacun d'accord sur les
termes du deal comme elle dit Benoît et
cetera elle est pas attachée tu la vois
attachée tu la vois non elle y va ça se
trouve c'est elle qui l'a dragué et en
plus c'est très sexiste tu tu dis qu'en
fait elle est pas à 18h pas de juger
c'est de de l'amour qu'elle lui peut lui
porter etc en fait il a son ascendant
psychologique mais tu es très sexiste en
fait
Jean-Michel maire d'une gamine qui a le
même âge
elle va pas tomber amoureuse quelque
part
aujourd'hui quand on va voir des mec de
19 de 40 ans elle va se dire j'ai pas le
dire à ma mère parce qu'elle est comme
ça elle le dira toujours à sa mère parce
que ma fille et moi on est comme ça sauf
que justement moi je pense que que après
ça dépend probablement d'éducation cette
jeune fille je ne sais pas ce qu'elle
recherche je ne sais pas pourquoi elle
va là mais lui il sait très bien ce
qu'il recherche en elle et
malheureusement elle en a pas conscience
ici moi je pense qu'on est en train de
remettre en cause toute l'histoire du
showbiz hein j'applin quand il a connu
sa dernière femme elle avait 19 ans ils
ont fait cette gosse il faut cautionner
donc là pour le coup honnêtement je vois
pas effectivement bon ben mets ton cul
il a peur vieillir et elle elle est un
peu vénale et ben oui c'est toutes les
semaines forcément
il y a des gens est-ce que je peux vous
dire quelque chose je vais vous dire
quelque chose quand j'avais 30 35 ans on
me draguait pas quand j'ai eu ça quand
j'ai je me suis approché de 50 je parle
pas des voitures de la télé il y a des
gens plus jeunes qui m'ont draguer moi
ça m'intéresse pas ce sont des gens qui
ont peur qui cherche des repères des
conseils qui ont envie de venir vers toi
c'est pas pour c'est pas du tout pour
ces choses là tout le temps c'est pas
vénal contre connu je suis d'accord avec
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça on se voit
des vidéos de la jeune femme j'ai un
petit doute mais de toute façon on s'en
fout c'est tout le chemise exactement
Sophie est pas choqué en tant que maman
je comprends Ludivine et cetera bon
voilà 19 ans c'est jeune à la fois c'est
un milieu qui est complètement différent
on parle de Léonardo Dicaprio elle sait
très bien il a eu plusieurs jeunes
filles comme ça de cette acabit là de
mannequins etc et elles savent très bien
les filles c'est un accélérateur de
carrière c'est un vrai booster d'être
juste amoureuse
de Zakaria vous êtes jalouse parce que
vous venez ici j'ai l'impression
j'ai une question pour toi très précise
vas-y ta caméra est là très bien j'aime
bien quand il y a la caméra voilà
tu as 20 ans
si je te dis pour de vrai voilà tu as 20
ans aussi jolie qu'aujourd'hui et
DiCaprio te drague fortement et même
veut t'emmener à Los Angeles et aimerait
vivre une histoire avec avec qu'est-ce
que tu dis mais jamais de la vie
j'ai eu 20 ans et j'ai eu l'occasion
d'avoir plein d'argent et de pouvoir
faire plein de choses DiCaprio qui t'ont
draguer quand tu avais 20 ans mais
d'autres mais qui mais
on m'appelle le Goldorak
il y a vraiment cette chose qui se perd
et tout à l'heure Sophia en parler
notamment ça se voit sur les réseaux
c'est le sens des valeurs je suis désolé
à un moment donné et pour moi ça va avec
l'éducation ok merci
tout d'un coup il peut ils servent ton
propos tout d'un coup ils ont des
valeurs je crois que les mecs du tout
justement c'est parce qu'ils en ont pas
sur les réseaux de pervers ils ont des
valeurs
et puis voilà il me ramène maintenant
bah ça me fait chier quoi
tu vas ou pas
dans l'autre sens que je veux
celle-là c'est moi 20 ans tu as 20 ans
il te drague du Caprio
un homme qui a 29 ans qui avait 29 ans
de plus que moi voilà ah oui c'est le
père de mes enfants on a vécu 15 ans
ensemble et c'est fort je te parle d'une
énorme star de 20 ans comme kendji
Caprio qui te drague tu réponds ou pas
bah oui j'y vais bah voilà merci toi
aussi
des énormes michto qui sautent sur
exactement
[Rires]
c'est le mec qui nautique on parle au
milieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les amis on arrêtera avec cette
conclusion et surtout qu'est-ce que
c'est pénible mais c'est vrai
y a plein des messages
je vais pas merci merci
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'enchaîne non mais bon quand on y va on
y va